[Musique]
action oui c'était pmp vous êtes clara
morgane voilà exceptionnel bonsoir plus
simple avis mais là on en dise ah ouais
c'est ça oui c'est ça
non je suis fan se lancer à l'eau ouais
partout qu avec qui et qui car à morgane
non vraiment je suis dit mais non il ya
pâtissier wagram
il faut pas stresser en 2003 est votre
copain séguin cette seconde runner
aujourd'hui justement jeunes et un trait
pour vous rendre honneur
qu'est-ce vous mes chers à ce tournoi
international les meilleures
spécialistes mondiales sont en piste
aujourd'hui le meilleur heures sont
passées disait voltaire dans un
c'était le tournoi international de
gerais et corbeil essonnes c'est énorme
je suis quelqu'un comme vous at elle
mieux les pires hp mais l'art est mais
non mais voyons mais non c'est vraiment
très bien on va prendre une photo
ensemble tout à l'heure jacques marié
avec josé dans scènes de ménages c'est
ça non moi je suis un chèque lire mes
blagues sur ce que tu en penses d'accord
ouais c'est un mec et chez les médecins
il laisse un petit village en avant mais
cela n'a mis que deux mois à vivre
bon ben je pense juillet août alors très
bien sauf que je la connais des gens
déjà fait pas ou feint pas ouf question
fait je veux juste que les autres
[Musique]
oh mon dieu et maman stinky sur un
quidam si bien papa sin qui arrive comme
ça
lundi signe elle est où la chute fait un
petit bébé un petit bond annoncé la bd
sin papa ou
mais qu'est ce que vous faites qu'est ce
que vous faites c'est du droit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ouais parce que partout les navettes qui
suis-je
je sais la fille qui joue dans nos chers
voisins la commune la bonne foi des
coupelles pourquoi bardot
vous pouvez mourir je suis plus arrêté
elle a ses limites et pas chez 2others
j'ai la haine en mai la bonne la 12è
dégueulasse je suis désolé vous m'avoir
gardé comme un mauvais nom je vous
n'êtes pas engueuler
vous arrêter pour faire pipi et je pense
qu'on fait si c'est avec tout vos
clients trompés chemin je vais pas faire
pipi dans la voix déjà énorme je sais
bien en faire écouter vous avez une
double personnalité c'était il y avait
des côtés très attachant et puis voilà
ça me dérange pas si on a deux secondes
pour pisser j'en peux plus rapidement
très rapidement
[Musique]
si le sort si le chauffeur de tauzin oui
c'est une caméra cachée ou pas il
appelle un pote on soigne à la brune a
c'est le quai dégueulasse ou l'autre
[Applaudissements]
mais il a un problème je jouis de
l'intérieur excusez moi du coup j'ai
arrosé des fleurs et bondoukou c'est
comme ça qu'on l'a
c'est notamment par le temps nous sommes
heureux que moi je préfère pas le passé
ce que je fais pas pour nous c'est pas
permis
la maman je suis désolé je suis
tellement content que je me suis chez
[Musique]
vous a donné un prénom en dessous c'est
ado je voulais faire pour m'attendre à
rognan c'est assez fréquemment à z ont
fait que pendant ce temps tony conte
magnifique mais je devrai son nom de
famille parce que de détente monica ses
mots ni comme boucle sa saison à midi
car eux à ses fans et à niko ah oui
d'accord j'ai compris j'ai kong
magnifique et je mets manson avec un
petit quart mais c'est faire un dernier
c'est moi qui vous la porte non pas
parce que vous avez du cac à justin
vous revenez au studio bienvenue dans la
grande brasserie c'est quand même
s'il venait une fois j'avais un gars lui
péter mais péter mais péter un truc de
ouf me péter dans la dans la cage
d'escalier vous avez des voisins qui
sont curieux la nuit là-bas man who
stares bien fait partie et c'est sur la
fin qu'on a su qu'il s'agissait de cyril
hanouna parce que vous avez été piégé
sur la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]